c'est avec le plus grand plaisir que je
vous souhaite la bienvenue à chacun de
vous 19 juin 1973 henry fort de deux
petits-fils du fondateur de ford vient
inaugurer la première usine ford en
france c'est jacques chaban delmas alors
maire de bordeaux et ancien premier
ministre qui est derrière ce projet est
très vite
ford blanquefort est en pleine expansion
en 1976 l'usiné était même en manque de
personnel
lusine qui a coûté près de 42 millions
de nos francs n'est cependant
actuellement qu'est la moitié de sa
capacité quotidienne de production c'est
pour atteindre ce rythme qu'elle a
besoin de personnel
un personnel qu'elle ne trouve pas pour
l'instant pour de multiples raisons
cette même année le site accueille sa
deuxième usine tout semble aller pour le
mieux pour l'entreprise et socialiser en
boîte de vitesses mais c'est une joie de
courte durée dès 1981 les 3600 salariés
sont confrontés à des arrêts de
production
ford blanquefort est un fleuron de
l'industrie française mais connaît sa
plus grave crise dans les années 2000
blocus de l'usiné de boîtes de vitesses
pas de plan social mais les syndicats de
ford hausse le ton en 2008 qui
manifestent au salon automobile
décidés à se faire entendre pour donner
un coup d'accélérateur à leur combat
avant de séquestrer leurs dirigeants
cette même année bref les salariés sont
au bord de la crise de nerfs bousculade
générale chez ford des salariés
exaspérés empêche la direction de passer
l'usiné de blanquefort ferme ce soir à
22h10 semaines de chômage partiel avec
70% du salaire
c'est ce qui a fait monter la pression
en 2009 or dans son usine de blanquefort
un repreneur allemand spécialisé dans la
production de pièces éoliennes
l'enseigne ford de lusine emblème
historique de la marque et même des
montées des images fortes qui sont
restés dans les mémoires
un symbole de l'industrie automobile
américaine décapité aujourd'hui à 17h à
blanquefort devant l'usiné devenue first
aquitaine industrie depuis le 1er mai
dernier
c'est un fiasco total pour le groupe
allemand résultats forts de revient en
2011 un léger sursis pour les 1600
salariés de l'usiné et pour combien de
temps encore sept ans plus tard la
marque à l'ovale bleu pourrait bien
disparaître définitivement du paysage
industriel d'ordonner
[Musique]
oh